je vois c'est ça qu'on problème cousin
tu concrétise pas des occases le foot
les filles c'est pareil faut partir du
principe qu'aucune équipe n'est
imbattable inquiet pour approuver la
généreuse de ma classe trois semaines de
travail alexandrine deux mois samia ces
deux jours si tu es musulman bien sûr en
constance était toujours sur anaïs et
pas trop défoncé 7,9 avait pas défoncé
et les mal dans sa peau tu comprends
rien ça fait trois mois que je travaille
dans deux mois je suis en finale ici on
remet tout peut arriver besoins
n'importe quoi c'est que tu parles de
champion de l'amour je connais mes stats
de la saison dernière cinq filles quatre
fois l'amour cette peep toe que tu dis
ça je dis pas que tu aies jamais sérieux
mais qu'est ce que tu fais mais il
reprend pas vraiment jamais mes loisirs
au jour où lens non mais jb arrête de
jouer perso partageront l'ancien je
pense collectif des bars des mois qu'on
peut chaloupés